A lot of people have positioned this
debate as,
you know,
just a battle between the tech industry
and the content industry and it's an
insider's game.
It's a bunch of rich guys playing around
with each other.
I don't think that's the case.
I think what we're talking about is,
um,
the freedom to innovate.
That's a very profound and important
thing.
First of all,
all of the services that,
that consumers across the web have come
to know and love.
You know,
there are 800 million people using
facebook.
The future of those services is at risk
and so your use of the Internet is
threatened by this legislation.
If the legislation passes,
it'll mean that you will pay more for a
lot of the things that you've come to,
uh,
appreciate.
Uh,
and,
and that are much,
much less expensive.
Beyond that,
there's innovation and there's the pace
of innovation is slowing down the next
facebook.
The next novel service that consumers
would get really excited about is,
is not gonna happen.
You know,
today,
one of the reasons the Internet has
produced such wonderful innovation is
that it's been very inexpensive to start
a company.
Foursquare got to 100,000 users on
$25,000.
That's unheard of in an era before the
open source software that everybody uses
to build on top of and the distribution
platform called the internet,
which the end users pay for it.
You know,
we all buy our,
our,
our access to the Internet ourselves.
And so no,
no,
no supplier of content has to buy the
access the way they used to in the cable
world.
And so by lowering the cost of creating
new new services,
we've dramatically increased the amount
of innovation.
The problem is,
you know,
foursquare is essentially started with
three people and they were able to get
to 100,000 users with five or six
people.
Um,
now we're going to have three people and
a lawyer involved in all of these
startups because,
uh,
as an investor,
we're going to be looking at these.
And the first due diligence question
you're going to ask is,
are you clean?
Is there any risk associated with
liability?
You know,
could uh,
one of these people come after you?
Could the attorney general come after
you?
What are you doing that might infringe?
And the definitions in this legislation
are so vague that no matter how hard
they try,
they're not going to be able to give
crisp answers to that.
So it creates a huge amount of
uncertainty,
which we'll chill investment,
which will chill innovation.
The real irony here is if you had to
pick the content industries,
least favorite company,
it probably be Google.
What's happening here is that Google has
about 200 lawyers on staff today.
It's not going to affect them at all.
They'll fight these guys,
they have the money,
they have the lawyers,
they'll just create a team and go fight
these guys.
But if you take a little search engine
startup like duck duck go,
which hopes to compete with Google,
which is innovating in novel ways and
creating a new experience for consumers.
They have three people.
If the fourth one has to be a lawyer,
they're never going to get there.
And the last thing is to come back to
this notion of the freedom to innovate
and why is that so important?
We have a bunch of really difficult
problems that we're facing over the next
few years.
And politicians sometimes say,
why are you spending time on,
on this issue?
It's an arcane insider issue.
Um,
but if you think about the problems that
we're trying to solve,
the Internet isn't the problem.
The Internet is the solution.
So just think about,
um,
the fact that no matter what,
we're going to go through a period of
dislocation as the economy evolves into
this more modern on this more modern
platform and people who are in their
forties are going to have to rethink how
they're making living.
They're probably going to have to be
more dependent on themselves.
There are going to have to find ways of
retraining themselves.
The way to do that is to use the
Internet to,
to make it possible.
If the,
the idea of retraining workers is done
as part of a government service through
a government institution in the old
industrial hierarchical bureaucratic
model of delivering the services,
it's going to be phenomenally expensive.
What we're seeing on the Internet is
really nifty education startups where
peers are teaching peers how,
how,
how to do things.
The cost of that is a tiny fraction of
the cost of the old industrial model of
producing these services.
So we need this medium to get us through
these really intractable problems.
So it,
it's not just a little inside baseball
argument between two rich kids,
you know,
it is,
it is a threat to the foundation of the
Internet,
which in turn is a threat to the
innovation that we need to dig ourselves
out of these,
these,
these really difficult problems.